what's up I'm Krista Stefano aka Krissy
contradictions and this is Yanis Papas
aka Yanni almost and we're both
stone-cold cuties we are all called
cuties with smoothies you may know us as
the Bay Ridge Boys aka the history
hyenas welcome yeah we have a lot of
different names mr. alien is the Bay
Ridge Boys it's just because we both
have mental illnesses that we're just
trying to make money off now yeah we're
both too disturbed individuals who love
history and we love hyenas because they
are and by all means necessary type of
animals yes and all the stuff that I've
said on this podcast has costing my
family but I don't care cuz I got you
guys got a new family now yeah it's just
we're both in a total blackout while
we're doing it we don't remember doing
the podcast we don't remember what we
said it's all the characters just the
character piece
these guys just Patrick so synthetic
jerk-off it's a clue see you're an actor
an actor you don't press me value
make-believe to other people you know
also does it my four-year-old daughter
Colleen yeah good morning welcome to
another episode thanks for waking up
with us it's weapon in the morning with
the history I eat is listen what we're
gonna do here every day we just rolled
out of bed I got out of bed three
minutes ago Yanis is still in bed so
what we're gonna do is I have my ruler
like we said yesterday I'm gonna measure
my morning wood to see if Corona gotta
and our penises I mean they came to
Paulie was an insecure guy I mean this
people think the kid was like 5 feet
tall 5 napoleon is the definition of a
squeeze [ __ ] squig I have a lot of
things that happen in my childhood that
are slowly coming out in therapy go to
patreon.com/scishow rich boys to find
out what they are yeah